I am just a man what else could one do
seeing Luggage in a minivan I have no
choice in the matter do you not
understand I check it once then I check
it twice ah ooh look what you made me do
look what you made me do look what you
just made me do look what you just made
me do look what you made me do look what
you made me do look what you just made
me do look what you just made me they
don't want to steal whiskey but they
must feed their
family my newborn loves py he's a boy
and he likes blue how do you expect
someone not to shatter all this glass
when he sees this while only carrying
the 14 Max any chance you might step up
to defend property rights I check it
once then I check it twice H ooh look
what I always do